to the donbass settlement
and fulfillment of obligations in the
minsk package
of measures mr zelansky yet again said
nothing of
specifics and he tried to put the blame
on russia for the settlement
in donbass as for the dialogue with don
bass
the president did not even mention that
and we paid attention to
the forum on security last week in kiev
where the cuban authorities have
mentioned the key task is the
preparation to fight against the
non-existent russian threat
zelensky spoke about the demand to
maintain expenditure on defense
at the level of no less than five
percent gdp of the ukraine
today ukraine is spending about
seven and a half billion us dollars per
year
on defense and that's
number one expenditure in the world
just like military's plans in kiev the
nato
presence is being built in the ukraine
and
in the black sea as you know
the 20 over the past 25 years there
haven't been such
exercises as this year's alliance
defenders europe with 25
000 officers and soldiers
from nato countries and eu allies
there will be also kazakh maze
silver saber
and sea breeze exercises also slated
for this year in 2021 on the territory
of the ukraine there are seven joint
exercises with nato countries planned
so every one and a half or two months
there are these or
other military maneuvers taking place
what does it tell us and what does it
lead to
i think that it's quite easy to analyze
that that does not help
inner ukrainian settlement on the 19th
of may
this year yet another meeting of the
contact group showed
yet again that there is no desire among
the ukrainian negotiators to act
according to the
veteran spirit of the minsk agreements
the donbass topic had an
unexpected development however strange
it met him
but as a as a part of palestinian
israeli
conflict exacerbation what does kiev
have to do with that
it seems but now and there was
a reason behind it the situation in the
middle east
gave an idea for the radicals
from the notorious ukrainian tour accord
to hold an
a rally in front of a russian embassy
and they have
expressed their condemnation
of hamas acting with the support from
russian authorities this crazy logic
well still that's the paradigm that
our neighbors are living in
at least those with a radical sentiment
there were anti-russian mottos and
offensive warrants being thrown around
our embassy had the entrance blocked and
our embassy has directed
a note of protest protest to the foreign
ministry
yet another there was a violation of
obligations to
fulfill the mints package of measures as
well as the failure to fight
aggressive nationalism and xenophobia as
well as
viennese convention on diplomatic
relations
yet another piece of news from that
state
we paid attention to the sentence on the
29th of
april of student in levof
who has thrown red paint on the monument
to
bandera and for that act
aimed against nazi henchmen and
fascists well i'm not going to give a
judgment
on that situation indeed there is law
and legislation and it's a sovereign
state
but there is also an important component
that has to do
with double standards in the implication
of this legislation and like to give
more detail on that
so for this action the young man has
received a four year sentence
the punishment punishment was later
substituted for two year
um
sentence served outside of prison
this is just yet another case of
selective justice
and persecuting those who do not agree
with the policy of whitewashing and
glorification of nazis in their henchmen
just to say that these are
and this is brutal sentence of the
evolved
chord gives us a vivid example of how
the modern ukraine responds
to the regular acts of vandalism towards
memorial burial places
in the ukraine those who fought to
liberate ukraine from the
from the nazi warriors
there are plenty of examples but what
i'd like to say
i will i'd like to mention a specific
case the consistent steps
steps to demolish the
military glory monument involved
desecration of monuments to mr batutan
to mr zhukov and and others these are
just a few examples
would have an hour would not be enough
to mention all of them because there is
a whole range of incidents starting with
2014 and
that has increased greatly and not
in a single case and that's critically
important here not in
there was a single case of prosecution
because
those to blame were not even looked for
i guess
as for the evaluation from the western
curators
of the kievan regime and then do not
give an evaluation because
otherwise they would have to respond to
similar
issues with historical memory
in the czech republic there for a very
long time there was a monument to the
liberator of
prague marshall konev who
saved the unique cultural heritage of
the
czech republic's capital sacrificed the
lives of thousands of soviet soldiers
bulgaria always has instances
of desecration of monuments to soviet
soldiers and the same goes to
poland and it just gives an idea that
the west does not only support the war
against the past but
with the revision of the second world
war they're also taking part in this
such falsification of history is going
on not only in the context of the
situation of the recent past
in the modern days the current situation
the current creation of history is
currently being subjected to
falsification just
before our eyes another example
the white helmets praised in the west
we've been talking about them a lot but
unfortunately
without due consideration of all fact
logical materials
in the west the situation still goes on
this pseudo humanitarian
organization but which in reality
is uh helping terrorists this
organization
is being sponsored
during the previous briefings we've been
evaluating the actions of this
organization
which is declaring its goal as saving
the peaceful population in the conflict
zone but actually
is dealing with misinformation false
flag chemical attacks
and just plain simple helping terrorists
the financing of this so-called
ngo is going through some sophisticated
schemes including through different
funds based
in the west we've been
giving you many materials and examples
one of the principal donors of the white
helmets is the fund the media rescue
with the
headquarters in amsterdam which was
receiving
contributions from the government of the
netherlands but in 2018
this fund finance flows have been
stopped because of the
fears regarding this the spending of
those
of those funds in some dirty scandals
which this organization is involved in
this was a true
situation that was uncovered that
netherlands journalists recently
published
testimonies that the government of the
netherlands
hid the information regarding the
supposed
fraud schemes on the part of the fund
and illegal operations
it engaged in as it became known
unnamed high-profile
officials were fearing to
shed light on the information regarding
the abuse
made by the mayday rescue allegedly due
to the lack of direct evidence
this story ended up just being silenced
and the white helmets continue to be
supported through a different
organization based in canada
the hague once again demonstrated the
policy of double standards
the hypocrisy and selectiveness of their
approaches regarding
the choice of unchecked information
to be introduced to the public the
united states of america the ministry of
foreign
of internal affairs of the united states
published
a report regarding the review of the
terrorist threats in the country
in which they've been accepting and
admitting
the increased activity in the recent
times of so-called internal terrorists
propagating the ideology of
religious and ethnic strife racial
supremacy
and militant nationalism
such evaluations by the experts
especially against the backdrop
of the current social and
racial conflicts in the united states
and the whole situation
are not news truly
it is worth noting that the authors of
the report while remarking new
tendencies of the spread of the
terrorist ideology
are insistently trying to focus
on the fact of the internal external
influence
accusing russia china and iran in the
alleged
malevolent activity to deepen the
division in the united states
and spread of conspiracy theories and
calls for violence including is the
backdrop of the current virus pandemic
citing the priority task of has
been mentioned against the risks of
internal violent extremism the
washington views it through the
traditional
geopolitical optics
still considering its main achievement
the
introduction to the national list of
internet of
international terroristic organization
of a russian ngo russian imperial
movement
some experts including the us experts
were puzzled
about this decision regarding the
lack of real information about this
organization and its
foreign connections this ngo this
russian ngo
has been touted by the american
authorities as the first
foreign organization spreading the ideas
of the white supremacy
it is worth questioning how the
readiness of washington to fight the
far-right extremism in racism is
combined
with its position and stands in the
national arena
where we see the propaganda and the
selectiveness
in the last year some american experts
offered to pay attention to the serious
danger
emanating from extremists groups of
neo-nazis in ukraine the territory of
this country
was turned into a platform for for the
training of radicals and spread of the
nazi
literature and attributes
criminals and and far-right
groups such as s-14
civil corps of azov national corps
still acting in this country and
organizing
congregations of nationalists from
baltic countries and other countries of
europe this these organizations maintain
partnerships with foreign neo-nazi
groups atomwaffen division in the united
states and the british national action
it is difficult to find explanation
why in this condition the american
authorities
introduced the russian imperial movement
into their into their list
and refused to do this in the regard of
the
ukrainian rights sector and azov
washington continues to vote against
the yearly resolution introduced by
russia to the general assembly of the un
which is dubbed the fight against the
glorification of
nazism
and uh neo-nazi xenophobia
and other practices that contribute to
feeling contemporary forms of racism and
racial discrimination xenophobia and
releasing tolerance
currently we have a lot of questions
coming in regarding the situation in the
middle east
i would like to comment on this
we are satisfied decision that on the
21st of may
there's been a cease-fire announced in
the area of israeli-palestinian conflict
the conflict lasted for 10 days in
russian diplomacy
was energetic and it's worked to
stop this conflict in the most swiftly
possible including through high-profile
consultations
we've been in contact with high profile
national partners
to alleviate the crisis situation we
also participated in the the
quartet in in the put it on the middle
east settlement
the conflict has caused life of hundreds
of palestinian securing children 52
children have died
and also tens of citizens of
israel we we mourn the deaths of
all of all the deceased
an important contribution to the end of
the country was made by the
u.n including through the special
coordination of the u.n and the middle
east
to avoid further violence
there was an important step made at the
current stage
not to not to let the violence continue
we need to focus on the creation of the
corresponding conditions to relaunch
direct political negotiations between
israel and palestine to settle
the fundamental questions of the final
status
based on the u.n resolutions and the
principle of two states
israel and palestine coexisting in peace
and prosperity of
1967. russia as a member of the unsc
calls for partners to continue this
energetic
collective work to resume direct
constructive
israeli-palestine dialogue
to a reach sustainable outcome of
this problem is a main prerequisite to
stabilize tuition in the middle east as
a whole
there have been a lot of questions also
recently
regarding the cooperation between russia
and kazakhstan in the biosecurity sphere
rich between our countries are pre are
privileged and
allied in character one of the
priorities fears of our cooperation is
biological security
as allies enables with the current with
the common space of
biosecurity we try to
carefully monitor the epidemiological
and other situations regarding to be
regarding biosecurity
and we try to jointly react to
infections and try to diminish risk
linked to the use
and the possible use of biological
agents as weapons one of the key
elements in this activity is the forming
of the corresponding
bilateral legal negotiation base
in this uh to accomplish this we i
we hope to conclude an intergovernment a
memorandum
on the questions of ensuring biological
security signing of this document would
influence the strengthening of friend
deliberations and biological security of
our countries and would
help develop our cooperation in the
medical and biological
center and epidemiological veterinary
and other domains
it this would also allow for
to avoid statements from
third parties and the
scientific and academia circles and the
media
in this regard
we intend to continue this cooperation
in a bilateral and multilateral
basis during the russian
and kazakhstani inter-agency
consultations
planned for the may 26th
in almata the situation
with coronavirus according to the
statements of international experts
including from the wh show
we are witnessing the slowing down of
the spread of the chronovirus infection
and the
slowing down of the mortality from this
infection
as of may 20th the number of new cases
of
infection diminished by a third this is
a
general statistic from the world
we're talking first and foremost
about countries where a lot of
population has been vaccinated
in separate regions of the world
especially in asia and latin america
the daily growth is still going on in
india this
this number represents approximately
half of the general
worldwide level it is obvious that this
process of immunization of the
population of the country is one of one
of the most important directions of the
international community
currently there have been more than 1.5
billion
vaccinations made we
share the concern on the part of the who
regarding the
spread of the immune modulators
and we support the call of the director
general of the organization to share
the current virus vaccines i think our
country is made
all is possible in this regard we will
continue to stick by our
stance we presume that
this this topic shouldn't be politicized
at any cost
this is our baseline position currently
in some resort countries
there are tendencies to lift
restrictions introduced due to the
pandemic
due to the coming of summer despite the
still shaky
dynamic in the epidemiological situation
these countries
are swift in opening their borders and
interests
of supporting the tourism industry and
then
assure their partners that there are all
measures of
intellectual security being implemented
in the airports and
hotel infrastructure and while
understanding the
striving of this of authorities of these
countries to restore international
tourism we should remark the situation
is with kobe 19 is still volatile
this could cause new emergency
restrictions including
the cessation of international
flights this we shouldn't go far for
examples
the situation unfortunately his
role is right with examples
foreign tourists that have found
themselves
locked in nepal and many other states
forces us to really consider the risks
linked with traveling abroad and we
address our citizens once again
with a request to consider carefully
when planning trips abroad
this is truly a critically important
question now turning to
the flights with the russian citizens
from
nepal on the 18th of may of may
the air flight made an evacuation flight
from kathmandu to moscow for tourists
who couldn't leave nepal after the
introduction by the authorities of that
country of a full
ban on international flights 253 people
have been
evacuated including 219 russian citizens
they've been also tourists from belarus
kazakhstan latvia lithuania
malta and moldova tajikistan and ukraine
aboard
we are grateful to the nepal authorities
for their cooperation solving questions
linked to the organization of this
flight
i can but thank the russian embassy in
nepal
which is uh constantly helping
russian citizens stranded in this
country despite
the warnings by the mfa
and finding themselves locked
i think all those missions and
uh ira flawed for the conducting this
operation
now turning to several topics related to
the visa questions
we've received several requests from the
media
regarding whether the citizens of the
countries
to russia resume direct flights to can
they
file tourist visits to russia and arrive
in this country
in our country as tourists we would like
to point out
the following according to the
paragraphs 14 15 of the article 2 of the
order of the government of the
federation
of march 16 2020 number
635 are temporary restrictions on the
entrance
into the russian federation are not
extended to the citizens
of foreign countries and people with
with a document confirming their right
to
for constant residence in this country
mentioned in nx number one to this
order
the those citizens can enter in russia
federation only through a direct flight
uh 28 countries are mentioned
in this annex there is no visa regime
with the 14 of these countries citizens
of other 14 countries
and persons another person can
receive any category of russian visa
including a tourist one and enter
russian federation in user order now
regarding the
citizens of those countries that
are still not have no direct fights
resumed with
according to period 2 of the order of
the government of the russian federation
there are certain categories of foreign
citizens and stateless persons
which according to paris six of article
five
of this order can receive certain
categories of visas
depending on the goal of their travel
we're also asked whether the
e-visas will be issued gradually
or it will be done only after all
all the borders have been opened for all
of 52 countries yet again i'll reference
the document of them
of the 16th of march 2020 decree of the
government of the russian federation
635r it had
that issuance of electronic visas has
been discontinued in order to ensure the
safety of the state
and health of the population and in
order not to spread the novel
coronavirus infection
so the foreign citizens can file for a
single e-visa
to enter the russian federation only
after all restrictions
have been lifted and we do not do not
know when it will happen yet another
announcement
in july this year for the um ufa
cup 2020 in st petersburg as for the
entry
in june and july as part of this
championship there will be need to
receive a certain persona
personal card so-called fan id a
passport of a fan
russian missions abroad have received
the necessary documents how to file for
for the fan id
and this fan id will give a chance to
enter the russian federation multiple
times from the 29th of may of 2021 till
the
2nd of july 2021 as well as
multiple exit from the russian
federation from the 29th of may to the
12th of july for
foreign fans the ministry
has also given the order to the russian
foreign missions abroad
to distribute as a priority visas to
media volunteers and participants of
sporting events as well as
other categories of foreign citizens who
plan to take part in the championship
as for the information and the way to
file for the documents will give you
additional information in the nearest
future
i'm also prepared to answer your
questions please
do we have the foreign life with us
colleagues international life
are you here we cannot hear you you're
muted
hello madam zakarba
in the recent interview you spoke about
the work on palestine in palestine and
israeli meeting and you have confirmed
that
you offered to hold it in moscow could
you tell me about the attitude of israel
to this initiative
as well as participants of middle
eastern quarter i'd like to confirm once
again what the russian leadership has
said
the russian proposal to hold direct
negotiations between the leadership of
israel and palestine with no
precondition still
remains in force palestinians have
said several times that they're
principally prepared for such a contact
the israeli are still holding out it
seems that western jerusalem
is not yet prepared with the palestinian
national administration
as for the position of the middle
eastern quarter of
international mediators regarding this
initiative none of the participants of
this mechanism
have expressed their concern about or
anything against it i'd like to mention
that unilaterally adopted u.n security
council resolution in 1980
in 1850 enshrined
enshrines the call to hold an
international conference in moscow
in order to work on this issue as well
as to hold them
to to conduct further destination of the
situation we believe it is important to
urgently call
a ministerial meeting of the quartet we
also
would like to call a ministerial meeting
of the quartet with key regional players
and as for the situation in palestine
and israel as i have already commented
that today's
agreement to seize hostilities has
showed once again that there is no
alternative
to so on the palestinian issue
at the negotiation table and we are
prepared to facilitate a direct
palestine
palestine israeli context to work on all
the compromised
solutions for the fundamental issues of
the final status
moving on do we have news front with us
yes we're here please
we do not have a lot of time because i
have the next event
back to back if you could be very short
in asking questions yes i'll try to do
that
in international news front agency the
bulkarian branch
i'm talking about the over care of
turkey about crimean tartars
on the 18th of may mfa of turkey
[Music]
mentioned a statement about the victims
of deportations of crimean tatars and
circadians
mentioned about the continued standoff
of crimean
tartars with them with a consequence of
deportation and turkey continues to
support the efforts to protect identity
also representative mfa of turkey
mentioned that
that that land has been occupied by the
atari zarya's russian 157 years ago what
does
the mfa think about that
what does the mfa think about such
statements of the
turkish and turkish party and what kind
of issues
and do the crimean tatars come across
and that turkey so
so really wants to solve that you know
what we think about that that these are
politicized and confrontational
statements it is only
much to our chagrin their continued
efforts by the official ankara to issue
a jaundiced vision of historical events
in destructive
to destructive goals and their own
serving their own political ambitions
and
these statements have nothing to do with
the real situation
with the real situation the republic of
crimea and northern caucuses
in particular there is russian
legislation and implementation of law
which guarantee
the full observation of
freedoms and rights of of human beings
in
according to international obligations
of russian federation
we're talking about specific solution of
issues with it that have to do with the
status of
crimean tartar language as a state
language expanding
their participation in the authorities
and socio-economic
life of the region russian ukrainian and
crimean tatar languages in the republic
of crimea
are state languages there are all kinds
of opportunities study them
in schools and universities there are
equal rights
and conditions to maintain the freedom
of religion
and freedom of speech
and freedom of national culture
intricate inter-religious and
international
inter-ethnic accord is one of the main
priorities
and that is confirmed that there is
great policy in place it's confirmed by
the survey
in 2020 96 of crimeans have evaluated
inter-ethnic and inter-religious
relations as
friendly with the support of the state
committee on the matters of inter-ethnic
relations the republic of crimea
there is an information portal in the
ukrainian language called
furious lives corrado 2.0
there is a newspaper krimsky vesnik
and journal crimea today hofnung
in german and russian torica in greek
and russian is war
in bulgaria and russian
the dove of maces in armenian and
russian
there is also to the tv channel millet
and radio bataan sedasi as well as
newspaper yani dunya and magazine eldes
if such statements as you have mentioned
by the turkish hemapha
indeed contain these facts at least once
they would understand how
improper it is to promote such
topics as as they do these are the facts
and we call upon the ministry of foreign
affairs
not to hide it from their own public
since
they're raising this topic as an
initiative
this show-off caring by turkey
about the situation with crimean tatars
in crimea with the fact that
before 2014 the authorities of this
country have
have been ignoring the multiple issues
in the observation of ethnic and
cultural rights of this
these peoples seems that it's only
a short-term idea it's also dubious that
the
turkish state is the protector of the
rights of ethnic minorities since their
own domestic issues of ethnic language
and religious nature
we are only several decades a wave
when from the time when the circadians
who lived in turkey had to hide their
ethnic identity
and their own language was even banned
but as mr lavrov says
we're polite people and we believe that
turkey
has to solve their own issues on their
own
also considering the obligations but if
this rhetoric continues
we'll also have to pay attention
to such issues in turkey and we wouldn't
want to do that
so i hope that the foreign ministry of
turkey will hear us today
we believe that it's high time that
turkey politicians abandoned
the using of ethnic factory as an
instrument of egypt
in geopolitical games which is
detrimental to
the interests of ethnic groups groups we
have plenty of issues
and areas and workflows where we can
interact with ankara
suggesting joint efforts we have
experience of such interaction
great experience let's use this
experience
let's not go into these things
do we have asian news information agency
yes
please go ahead sayed asian news
information agency the media has shown
information that the ministry of foreign
affairs
mr lavrov and state secretary of the u.s
mr blinken have discussed the issues of
mutual interest including afghanistan
could you speak
in more detail about that whether there
were some specific agreements
reached on afghanistan indeed
afghanistan
was on the agenda of bilateral
conversation
which took place in reykjavik
afghanistan was discussed during the
meeting
between mr lavrov and mr blinken this
issue
remains one of the areas where there is
efficient work between the us and russia
and ministers have positively evaluated
the situation there
and special representatives have also
mentioned that coordination of efforts
and inter-afghan
reconciliation as as u.s russia
and china and pakistan do help achieve
reconciliation
in the islamic republic of afghanistan
do we have armenian
public tv yes this is public tv
armenian tv azerbaijani authorities
have demolished the dome of the armenian
church in
sushi under the guise of renovation
in order to change the architectural
image of the church
and in violation of the and security
council resolution
they're stating anti-scientific
theses about the urbanization of
armenian churches of artsakh
what does russian side think about this
as a culture of the means group
the topic of maintaining cultural and
historical heritage in accordance
karabakh
has been constantly discussed with baku
and with yerevan
it has been discussed during the working
visit of the ministry
of foreign affairs of russia to armenia
and zerbajan
in early may we're promoting
speedy organization of unesco mission to
the region we're also working within the
means group of the osce
on the 13th of april 2021 there was a
statement adopted
which mentions that protection of
religious and cultural heritage
is one of the issues that require us by
john and romania to
put in additional efforts
do we have slovakian journalists here
yes we're here hello
the sound
relations between russia and slovakia
has lately deteriorated however
recent celebration of the victory showed
that slovakia
has many people who are for friend
relations with russia
they tried to prevent the revision of
history that the russians have
liberated us not the us this article has
gained
many likes and many reposts so the
politicians from slovakia
have addressed the leadership for
slovakia to normalize relations
with russia what does russia think about
it does it want to normalize relations
with slovakia
what do you think about the future of
cooperation between the countries
well as for the appeals that you're
talking about i have no such information
but i can talk about the position of our
country
in the context of building interaction
with slovakia
we're interested in
calm constructive and mutually
beneficial
relations with all the states and
slovakia is no exception here
as for the truth about the great
patriotic war in the second
world war you have been correct in
mentioning the absurdity of the policy
aimed at revising and redrafting history
is giving birth to the whole wave of
um believing that it's not proper
and a rejection of that but
nato countries well not them but rather
the locomotive built into the
nato architecture which was aimed at
spreading disinformation
and information campaigns to
revise the facts of that time um
actually
change changed the whole narrative they
wanted to give people
an idea about new um
new a new version of events
to change to whitewash
criminals and to give a new version of
the beginning of the war and the
outcomes of the war
and to do that in contrary to the
decision
of the nuremberg tribunal but all that
was
in vain and the people who are
under this information campaign
including by nato
it has it's been spread not only through
nato structures but also through
other institutions and we talk about
that quite often
engaging mass media of the western
states
so it turned out that that
cheekiness that lies that were
that was the basis for that campaign was
the righteous the reason for the
righteous anger among the people and
that
that actually makes us respect people
who do not allow
in the european countries to they don't
allow to make fools of themselves
which was the goal of such campaigns
demolishing the monuments to heroes
inventing
stories about non-existent heroes and
making heroes of people who are actually
collaborating and henchmen
nazis and people don't let make fools on
themselves they know that there are
facts in historical materials monuments
memorial complexes there is a decision
by the nuremberg tribunal that there is
documental videos and there are
public organizations who have been
dealing with these issues
for many years now and they haven't been
created in the 90s and the arts
with the money from brussels and nato
but those who were
based on the historical
memory that was brought to us by the
veterans
and participants of that war dear
friends
if you do allow i'd like to wrap up the
briefing at this point but we'll
continue to talk to
the media in a very short time
but during at the press center of task
news agency
will be holding a news event dedicated
to
the competition leaders of russia so
we'll see you later there thank you so
much if you have any questions left
which i did not have time to answer
today
please send them
send them in and we'll respond swiftly
thank you so much
take care bye bye
so
you